allez allez allez allez allez au boulot
là au boulot la vieille [ __ ] le boulot
c'est ma mère monsieur n'a pas fait un
client je suis seul frein puisses tu es
vraiment nul
si vous aimez talent et si vous aimez
les grosses budget une affaire pour vous
regardez c'est ma mère
venez venez sur ma mère allait pas cher
du tout non mais c'est la souplesse quoi
est ce que tu es là souvent moment
évidemment monsieur
alors pour passer à 18 heures
hu jinta mois 5 j'ai un rendez-vous une
matière non plus loin là bas c'est
vachement important c'est un gars qui
nous fuyait à la corde et vous repassez
après par là je vous offre le pin ça
pour passer sous la rubrique ok ça vous
dirait de lui grimper dessus pour 50
francs ok il est d'accord ils ont
repassé de thaler et toi qui aime bien
les vieilles jeu ma mère qui est quand
même mieux ses 50 francs c'est normal
qu'il y ait des députés dans le quartier
comme ça des [ __ ] monnaie de paris et
pépé était député je dis ma soeur est à
pigalle ça ça marche bien mon père est
rue sainte-anne et s'est fait casser le
croupion deux fois ce matin on l'a fait
un petit peu de chiffres bah ouais je
sais pas s'il ya autant de défis
maintenant il ya plus de travestis
maintenant je vois mon oncle qu'est-ce
qui fait comme pognon c'est étonnant
harry étonnant hein et puis on m'a
refilé du coeur à l'ouvragé
il peut faire 80 militaires date il est
vraiment laid comme edith vous toujours
que tant qu'on a la santé
enfin c'est 80 militaires ainsi pour
rien dégrader tout voilà oui madame vous
est pas resté là non plus cette fois
second tour annoncés annoncent-ils vais
pas y avoir de fuites sur le trottoir on
est d'accord si je m'excuse moi j'habite
ou cependant pas une [ __ ] à part dont
elle attend pour moi alors j'ai déjà à
cause de la coiffure oui oui parce que
je m'attendais c'est ma mère l a pas
fait un client de plus de 4 ont alors
dans une bulle qui ne fait pas de
clients on peut considérer que ce n'est
pas une [ __ ] je vous dise qui je suis
oui s'il vous plaît bon et bien mais ce
que je suis la tâche et du huawei oui
monsieur de cet [ __ ] d'avoir la
gentillesse de demandes
merci monsieur bourges tenait le pis je
vous donne les pin's vous allez gagner
le pin's
ah les mamans comme en 40 et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu